[Music]
hello everyone my name is nari sol and
this week i decided to write something
with the static baseline thank you to
james for this idea
the central theme sits somewhere between
using a drone or a long pedal point and
using an ostinato
there are elements of each term that end
up meaning the same thing and in this
case meant that the baseline remained
constant and the piece generally stayed
in the same place
[Music]
so i came downtown to film this because
i want the music to be a sort of
background to whatever scene i end up
going with and i think i can find
something interesting
the music to me is sort of
like a mist that just fills the air
again with this
drone type aspect to it it's not really
going anywhere and it's just
penetrating the air
that's how that's how i
feel about
it i was also inspired by chopin's
andante pianato which contains a pattern
in the left hand that repeats with
slight variations for the majority of
the piece
[Music]
i find that patterns like this one can
be broken up into different parts that
overlay onto each other creating a sort
of momentum within the pattern so that
when it's repeated it doesn't sound as
tiresome as a pattern that's maybe
boxier something like this maybe
[Music]
so along the lines of that i see this
part as having at least three or four
different layers going on at the same
time the base
the d
[Music]
the g's
[Music]
and the top
[Music]
so all together it creates a sort of
balanced momentum so similarly the
pattern that i came up with
has a drone or a pedal point however you
want to look at it
so the d
then the a
[Music]
and the top
those are at least three things that i
see in this pattern
[Music]
and now here's the piece
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to briefly go over the harmony the main
pattern in the left hand consists of the
notes of the d major scale
minus
the c sharp for now
over that i have a b7
[Music]
the second part of that
introduces the major seventh of
the d major seventh chord
[Music]
in the next part i see the notes of the
right hand as being an inversion of
an f-sharp seven chord
which creates this kind of sound
and i like it because when the chords
are together
[Music]
there's both
the perfect fifth
and an augmented fifth
in the middle section of this piece
it's basically an a minor 7 add 9
over d
which resolves into an a6 add 9
over the same d
[Music]
and then afterwards it returns back to
the first part another note about the
chords in the beginning
[Music]
even though it's a simple
d major with a b7 on top
i find that this sound works best when
the notes in the left hand or the bottom
half is a little more open
[Music]
there's a little more resonance that way
as opposed to
it being closed
like this
if i was to open this
it's a little ordinary
because this octave
sticks out
and it's stable because i hear this
but
with an open
fifth sound here
that's not the case
anyway those are just some notes on the
harmony and that is all
[Music]
where's guard maltese
how is bobby
how is he
oh my god this is like over the top that
i'm just eating oh this is not
this does not look like bobby
no not at all looks mad
the dog is angry